Hello my name is Emma and this is my friend
gizmo and today we are going to help you learn
English.
Today's English is all about dogs so let's ask some
questions to gizmo.
Anne we can get some answers.
Our first question do we call pets key she or
it?
What do you think gizmo?
Usually, for pets, we like to use he or she
OK,
so you might ask somebody what's her name or what's
his name.
When you're talking about a dog or a cat.
We usually use it for wild animals,
although sometimes we also use.
He and she if we want to personify them so
majority of the time we use,
he or she were talking about pets.
OK, question number 2? What is pet hair called?
Do you know the answer to this one gizmo?
It is called fur FUR fur as you can see
gizmo has a lot of fur.
We use the word fur when we're talking about Pat
her dog hair hamster her.
It's what we call fur.
OK, our next question what are pet hands called?
Let's show gizmos off so gizmo.
What is this called this is a paw so dogs
and cats have paws just going to put gizmo down
for a second.
There you go OK, so his hands are called pause.
OK, our next question what does canine mean?
9 is another way to say dog but canine is
more scientific sounding so if you're reading.
A science book or something that's formal writing you will
probably see the word canine it's the science scientific word
for dog.
We also have the word puppy?
What does the word puppy mean?
Puppy means a baby dog OK.
So when a dog is very small and very young
usually around you know 2 months to one year,
we call it a puppy.
For kittens that's what we call a baby cat a
kitten.
OK, our next question is very good one what sound
does a dog make sounds are very cultural in different
cultures animals make different sounds for dogs in English dogs
can either bark. They can say woof woof or they
can say Ruff Ruff is this different than what dogs
say in your language.
If you're wondering with cats or with you know all
sorts of other animals.
You can actually check out Ronnies video,
which covers a lot of these different animal sounds if
you're interested.
OK finally our last question for vocabulary?
What do you call a dog with no home so
a dog that lives in the streets we call a
dog with no home.
A stray dog or we can also say a street
dog.
So we would say that dog has no owner,
He's without a family. He's a stray dog or he
is a street dog.
So now let's look at some grammar and pronunciation and
cultural tips.
About dogs. OK. So our next question is a grammar
question,
and it's a very important grammar question.
OK, so let me hold gizmo OK,
so gizmo you see these 2 things.
I like dogs. I like dogs do you know what?
The difference between these 2 sentences are?
No OK well let me tell you.
I like dog is very different than I like dogs.
When you want to say you like dogs as in
you.
You think they're really cute and funny and you enjoy
them You say,
I like dogs with an S?
This is different from I like dog with no S
if you say,
I like dog. It makes it sound like you like
to eat dog and this is true for a lot
of animals if we say,
I like chikin. It means I like to eat chick
in this is very different from.
I like chickens, which means I think chickens are cute.
I enjoy chickens. And I find them very interesting,
so the next question is a pronunciation question.
And that is what is the pronunciation difference between dogs
and Ducks so a duck is an animal you know
that says Quack Quack at least in English.
It does an a lot of students when they say
these words pronounced them the same way so people don't
know if you're talking about a dog or a duck
So what is the difference in pronunciation?
Well dog has a different vowel sound,
then duck. Dog is longer we say dog.
Compare this to duck, which is very short and a
bit sharp.
This is an aw sound dog.
Versus. Duck. OK, so you notice the vowel sound here
is short,
whereas the vowel sound here is long.
When we add an S to dog and an S
2 duck,
we also have a different sound.
In dog because of the G the S becomes as
sound as in zed so we say dogs.
You might not hear it,
but there's a little bit of sound at the end
of that dogs now.
This is different from Ducks,
which has a sound or an S sound so there
is a pronunciation.
Difference say this one short with a sound and this
one is longer with a sound.
OK, great, so now let's look at some cultural questions
about dogs.
OK so our next question what do North Americans think
of dogs and a lot of people in England think
about dogs this way in Australia and this isn't everybody,
but this is what a lot of the population think?
What is their opinion on dogs well let's get gizmo
to help me out gizmo come here?
I'm going to pick him up.
Here we go OK. So,
in North American culture dogs like gizmo are often treated
like family members.
Some people even treat them as if they are there
children,
although this is not everybody but they really do care
about their dogs and they treat them like family?
Right This is gizmo's first time on camera so if
he's a little nervous.
He's never been on camera before.
Alright let's look at the next question small talk,
so dogs are actually a really,
really good. Oh, you want buddy economics down.
Sorry, OK, so dogs are actually really good topics for
small talk if you ever have a conversation with somebody
and you see they have a dog talking about their
dog is a great thing to do.
So if you're in the elevator or at the park
and you just want to meet somebody you can ask
them about their dog.
Here are some great questions.
You can ask them what's your dogs name?
What's his name. Is your dog a boy or a
girl?
Is it a male or a female?
How old is your dog?
How long have you had your dog for OK so
another really good question is?
What kind of dog do you have so in this
case were asking about the type or the breed so
there are many different breeds or types of dogs.
There are Chihuahuas. There are German Shepherds Shepherds Poodles Dalmatians.
There are tons of different types of dogs gizmo in
case you're wondering.
That app so pappillon mix beautiful breed and so people
do like talking about this.
You can ask them about their breed are they mix
are they a purebred which means they're only one kind
of dog like a poodle.
There's so many different questions.
You can ask about dogs,
but it's something people really love talking about so I
highly recommend if you see a person who has a
pet.
It's something that's a good thing to talk about.
OK, so like I said our pets are like our
family here.
Oh, thank you. Gizmo for that.
Kiss so one thing I wanted to say is that
a lot of the Times in North American culture.
You'll actually see that dogs are indoor dogs.
They're not, outside a lot.
They're actually they actually stay inside with us a lot.
Sometimes they sit on their couches.
And for some people they even like might share like
the same bed or they might sleep on the same
bed that their owner has.
Cultural thing that you might notice if you ever come
to Canada at or North America is that a lot
of dogs actually wear clothes here and gizmo is also
he wears clothes, too, especially in the winter time because
it does get very cold,
so a lot of dogs have winter boots and winter
jackets,
so if you come here don't be surprised to see
that sometimes people dress up their dogs for fun.
Other times, it's a necessity because it is very cold
during the winter.
OK, so gizmo and I would like to thank you
for watching you know,
we've had a great time.
Today I think isn't that right gizmo.
Yeah, he's a bit sleepy now,
so he's just going to say bye so we hope
you subscribe to our channel and we have a lot
of other resource is there and if you come check
out Ingrid at WWW dotinternet.com you can actually take a
quiz on everything we learned today,
so thank you gizmo for your help today and I
hope you enjoy this video.
Take care.